you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Leech SOR
and I'm playing a 3-2 game against Floyd
tic which is our first scheme alright
let's occupy the center and defend efore
I'm not sure what I'm going to do
against g6
I may try something with f6 okay going
with a 6-year mmm-hmm I wonder a little
bit about f4 Knight f3 but b5 comes
pretty quick Knight f3 let's just go
with the Knight to f3 I don't know if
this is best but I'll give it a go
unbe 5 they're threatening to give my
knight a kick and then take here ok so I
have no worry of Bishop g4 so let's
develop my bishop here maybe e5 and then
open this diagonal at some stage I'm
expecting them to eventually play e5 to
be honest so I think that there's a some
time wasted with this otherwise they
always have to deal with this e5 push
and that said maybe I should opt for
Queen e2 first instead of the routine
castles King side may end up still going
king side but I want to be in a position
of play e5 if they play Knight d7 so I
could King side castle I probably should
because they're quick to maybe expand if
b5 I think that's the moment to play
here maybe maybe I do this no matter
what black does this is probably you
know top candidate move let's do this
before they establish a pond here this
just opens up the position for so many
pieces Bishop Knight and Queen can make
use of the foreign threat and mate so
that's pretty serious may even be good
to do
right now another consideration is to
transfer my knight to the Kings side
make use of e4 before d5 is played but
what about a queen transfer I think it's
worthwhile to get this in and if they
play g6 they I have Bishop h6 f5 is a
very serious well it's a weakening move
it could be played
f5 takes and then Knight takes to defend
me and protect you 6 so they've weakened
their Kings side with this f6 and h6 has
my attention Bishop h6 they have to play
Knight g7 but really what I want to do I
think their Knights going to go to g7 no
matter what let me hmm I'm thinking
about moving my night to play c3 but
that's a bit too defensive let me be
more direct here yeah I think this is a
moment where I should be pretty direct
I'm one move away from completing my
development and they still hadn't need
several moves I was considering this to
meet this with here but there should be
something direct here I like this idea
of exchanging dark square Bishop skating
my queen on h6 and my night on g5
looking for made on h7 this is if they
don't do this now I think I could
maintain my pawn on e5 maybe they're
still considering this advanced with
some idea of throwing a punch against my
queen we'll see we have this increment
still Bishop g5 Bishop here so they're
going in for that
okay I guess I guess I have to take care
I'm helping them to develop some uh-huh
okay well there's no serious punch being
thrown at me just yet
I have d4 protected mm-hmm well maybe I
do like this move now
since night g7 isn't there I don't think
that this is so helpful f88 it's not
like the e-file is opened maybe rook a
to d1 okay to do you one or what about
d5 actually no d5 Knight f6 let's go
opposite their Queen my queen is a
little bit shaky I guess I do have the F
for square on Knight f6 Queen f4 they're
still behind in development this could
be an issue for them my bishop on h6
I do have a back rank mating ideas
potentially I'm just looking at getting
my rook involved in throwing in a flight
square and right now actually I'm
threatening to take the pawn so and how
would I recapture I think I want to take
with the Queen
not sure why I think this kind of fear a
bit fearful of e5 with the fork but
that's not hitting quite yet I think
I'll just take what the Queen
they have c4 but just back up my queen
always has these retreat squares or even
on time they're really going into the
think tank on this one okay maybe that
is is 9:05 the idea like I will I could
grab that pawn okay my knight belongs
here because my bishop also needs a new
square let's get there he's a very
strong piece and now I will I will
definitely take with the Queen I don't
want to
demote my knight like that this is a
fantastic position for my night and hmm
let's throw a punch at the knight on f6
so weakness there with that last move
means not defending f6 I have a good
piece play pieces are on good squares
Knight f5 is maybe an idea although I
could take the bishop and then play g4
oh man they just lost on time mmm okay
right one and things were heating up
there hmm that's not the the greatest
and results to came let's see I felt
like I was in the better position here
before I look at it with the computer
getting this in right here mm-hmm
c5 yeah again my other consideration was
if I just bring this up here don't want
the arrows okay there's no arrow stuff
just yet yeah my other consideration was
night here to me this with this and on
takes takes you know basically I keep my
e5 pawn in other words
okay now the arrows are coming up let's
just keep him off for a moment I think
this was another idea although you don't
just for that moment the computer was
calling out for Bishop h6 I must be the
better side here because I just have
this space advantage and a lead in
development and I don't see that this is
a case of upon being overextended in any
way it is in no way a liability black is
on the retreat and it's white who's
throwing punches and black who is having
to react this was the other move to
consider yeah this is certainly a big
move as if I'm retreating then this lead
that I have timewise physician physician
wise on the board you know they could
close it up in time is not so much of a
factor anymore I would still be the
preferred side I believe but I don't
think that I would retrieve my queen I
believe I would keep the physician open
because I have a better development so
I'm willing to keep I will or I want I
should say I want the position to open
up to make better use of my developed
pieces so they could play f5 and on
takes the knight recaptures defending h7
defending e6 and now I have to make a
move with the Queen yeah and now I could
just simply retreat like this and he has
some pressure on him and it's not quite
sure where this night belongs these guys
you know there's only one good square
for a knight here and it's on f6 I guess
this is a possibility Knight h4 into f4
hmm maybe my pieces are all my minor
pieces are really drifting towards the
Kings side and I still like I still like
my position even though this might be a
nice square for black to pivot about on
hmm I don't know yeah this Knight g5
move is maybe pretty serious know if you
go straight in maybe I could play Queen
III I don't know a rook retreat and then
think about striking here and here yeah
this could be serious you know given
some time if I'm if I'm not acting
quick to try and get in a Knight g5 move
like let's say going here if they have
time to somehow get the the other Knight
to f4 that can be a great bother but
does black really have the time to do
that I don't think so
so anyhow I just want to look at this
other alternative that I thought was
possible in the game
I was certainly going to capture keep
the position open and then go from here
knight Knight to e4 because he doesn't
really have much of a purpose on c3 and
Bishop may be somewhere yeah I'm looking
to go towards the Kings side keep the
position open so yeah I thought I
thought maybe after you know I'm not
really a big fan of e6 maybe they could
have tried Knight here within this
advanced however I'm getting an e5 real
quick and then maybe I could even think
about this kind of a pawn sack yeah
definitely like this I don't know I
guess this is an alternative as well but
it seems a little bit slow Bishop to e7
they let me build up for this e5 advance
see what the computer says but right
around here I still like my position I
think better is to take and then play b5
Bishop here compare this position with
the the what happen in the game where I
played Knight to e5 and I was able to
easily challenge the strong bishop on b7
you know this is maybe not so much of an
inconvenience from a bishop to play to
e2 because I will I will get my Knight
to e5 and I will find a good way to get
my bishop activated as it stands right
now this diagonal is not such a you know
he's not really doing so much he's
fighting on a rock
but yeah they ended up that's such a an
anti climactic ending there just a loss
on time in a position that was just
starting to get really interesting but
let's see what the computer is saying
throughout it's only giving a slight
pull where there may be some tactics
yeah okay so after Knight there what is
it suggesting putting on the arrows I
wants to take first and then play Knight
here but we avoid the exchange and think
before rook to d1 no I don't know if I'm
really so much a fan of this
allowing the night to hunt down my
light-square bishop I'd be I must admit
I'd be a bit more inclined to just take
care and yeah I do I do like this idea
of c4 because my concern once again in
this position is the night looking to
exchange himself off for my light square
Bishop Knight c5 so c4 striking at the
center allowing a retreat for the bishop
you know one reason is usually good
enough for me in many cases but if you
could have more than one good reason to
move forward with a certain move you
know
c4 I think is a good one for for these
reasons striking at the center allowing
a retreat night c5 Bishop c2 d 451 you
know pretty natural moves getting the
pieces working avoiding the knife er
Bishop exchange so this was an
alternative if we did have a capture on
e5 take stakes tonight here I would take
again and then strike at the center but
he went in Reverse right away on the e5
push and this allows a pretty
significant advantage Bishop h6 it wants
to go with I didn't see what the great
fall would be after night here well I
just wants to take a step out of the way
queena for making way for a night here
Oh
additionally additionally this keeps
pressure on d6 this Queen f4 move so
there is no c4 c5 strike because I could
take I didn't I didn't recognize this
idea you know during the game what was
maybe what was the reasoning I kind of
expressed for playing Bishop to h6 I
thought well he's gonna go here anyway
you know Bishop h6 isn't winning the
rook you know he has to go here anyhow
to reroute but with this move you're
pulling the night away from the defense
of d6 with Queen f4 it's
if you're helping your development out
it's not a developing move Queen f4 but
it's clearing the way to improve the
position of another piece this is
certainly a desirable square for the
Queen night putting pressure on d6 but
it also eyes this what I would identify
the most sensitive point in blacks
position f6 a because it's a hole in
being I already have pawn support for it
so it's calling for f6 here I think it
popped up at one stage d5 and yeah from
here we would look to reroute the knight
the d5 move kills this guy he's out of
play and it's pretty much a wise idea to
get him into the action on the Kings
side right now so that you can meet c5
with c3 and unn takes your reinforcing
your strong center point e5 you're
maintaining control over that gap in the
black position on f6 okay
well I went with Queen g5 they want what
c5 takes takes
were there any tactics missed it likes
the C form of that's surprising
suggesting I capture it's only something
slight here that I have so I should have
gone with Bishop to h6 and then push
Bishop to e2 Knight d5 yeah I guess I
have to be a little bit careful because
you know this natural move b5 Bishop b7
okay but Knight d5 what is this what is
this doing this is allowing for maybe
Knight f5 it's opening up this diagonal
the knight f5 striking at the dark
square bishop if I'm taking I'm helping
out there light square bishop hmm and we
have a bit of a mysterious move Queen c1
I'm not sure
what the issue is there suppose here
Knight f5 ooh
my bishop might be in some trouble here
huh f6 g5 Knight f7 or f5 my bishop is
kind of in no-man's land
okay yeah that would certainly be
something to be on the lookout for huh
although that's tough to see from this
current position that the bishop might
be in trouble because you have this we
have this knight move that's clearing
the way for f6 and g5 that takes this
idea Wow okay they went with the b5 they
had a moment where they had a half pawn
advantage and then you know I don't know
what more to say this is gonna happen
from time to time I guess I've had my
share fair share of losses on time but
yeah just when things were heating up
here yeah when I go to record a video
it's regardless of the result I it so
unfortunately this one ended like this
but I still hope as usual there is
something for you to take away from this
video and yeah I still hope that you
were able to get something out of it
even though not the greatest ending
already that's all for now take care bye
you